well the actions of france are wrong and
disproportionate and they need to
release the seized vessel uh soon and
make sure that the crew can get back to
what they should be doing which is
fishing at this time of year we do need
to establish the facts here and i raised
this in the house of commons yesterday
because it looks like that the fishing
boat that has been seized actually did
have the correct fishing license but the
list given to the european union and
france by the uk government didn't have
that boat on now if that was a
spreadsheet error and oversight that
needs to be corrected swiftly by the uk
government because we don't want to see
this escalate any further that is only
one part of a much bigger problem the
botched brexit deal that we've seen
over the past few months has frankly
made uk fishers incredibly angry
incredibly betrayed but the same
feelings held by french fishes so
there's not one side feeling like
they're winning or here both sides feel
like they're losing and what we need to
get to a solution is that tensions are
lowered on both sides of the channel
where there's a clear plan to how they
resolve this because bear in mind that
the longer this goes on the further risk
of disruption the more jobs will be lost
in the uk because this time of year is
absolutely critical for british seafood
exports where they're exporting into our
largest markets which is uh the european
union and if
customers in the eu are seen well this
is going to be difficult they'll get
their fish from elsewhere and that means
job losses here so it makes our fishing
industry poorer that's why a solution
has to be found and found early
and how are you sticking by uk fishermen
in your constituency
yes i'm as well as looking after fishing
in the shadow cabinet for labor i
represent
the south of plymouth which has nearly a
thousand jobs in fishing and what what
they're looking for at the moment is for
people to be relentlessly supportive of
the british fishing industry not only
buying british fish when you can in
supermarkets and in the shops
but making the case for british fishing
because they had a lot of promises made
to them by the government leading up to
our withdrawal from the european union
and those promises were broken they were
promised extra fish extra fish quota and
sadly the extra fish we seem to got seem
to only swim on on spreadsheets they
don't really exist in the seas they
can't be caught and importantly they
were promised that foreign boats would
not access the waters closest
to the uk mainland and that promise was
again broken so they feel really
betrayed by this so there's not a lot of
trust in the uk government to defend
their corner but they're also aware how
they were used as a political football
in the past and they don't want to be
used as a political football again but
fishers just want to catch fish and earn
their money by catching fish and that's
what we need ministers on both sides of
the channel to focus on to allow
uk boats that do fish in french waters
to do so unimpeded uninterrupted so they
can legally uh catch what they're
supposed to but also where there are
french fishing boats and eu boats in our
waters where they have a legal right to
do so they should also be able to fish
but we shouldn't accept any further
demon uh reduction in the rights of
british fishers because frankly they've
been betrayed enough since brexit and we
need to make sure that we're backing
them fully
but the best way of doing that is
lowering tensions and letting them get
on fish
yeah so you mentioned that b word there
brexit so do you pin the blame on this
rowell on brexit
well if you're looking back to
the root causes of much of this it's the
botched brexit deal that promised so
much to british fishing and delivered
very little that's really reduced the
confidence that british fishers have in
the uk government to stand up for them
because the promises that were made were
not kept equally if you look on the
other side of the channel many of the of
the uh of the promises made to french
fishes they don't feel has been kept now
what we need is ministers to recognize
that the way out of this is not by
building up tensions not by continuing
to press ever more aggressive language
we need to
put calm heads and call hands on the
tiller to make sure that we are finding
proper solutions for this because my
fear here is that british fishing will
again be the uh be the losers of this uh
if we don't have that clear solution
because uh you know you had george
eustis the environment secretary on your
program earlier um he has presided over
sadly
a real erosion in trust between uk
fishing uh
industry and the government the way they
can rebuild that is not only to be
strong and supportive of uk fishing to
get this crew back but if a mistake has
been made by a uk fishing authority not
to include the license of the boat
that's been detained by france on the
list given to france ministers need to
own up to that pretty soon be clear
about it because further tensions like
this does nothing to find a solution and
we need the fishers to be doing what
they're doing best getting out there
catching amazing sustainable fish
putting it on supermarket shelves
especially at a time when there's so
much disruption in the supply chain we
don't need any further disruption